all right we'll get started
but andrew is another colleague of mine
is more doubtful than me so he's gonna
represent how to build an application
all right so
just to brief agenda for today is why
yarn right so there's a lot more
to
hadoop2o and what yarn offers and then
we'll talk about the architect and
concept and then andrew will go into
building applications and we have a
sample applications we have built
you can go on our github copy it and
just reuse it for
your views
for the next step we'll talk about a
little bit how other
companies are building applications on
yarn what we have available today on
europe and how you can get
the code either from a github or from
our website or from our dashboard all
right
so we all know this diagram right on
this side so this when we started hadoop
or actually when
so our team started building hadoop
in around 2004
and then one of the primary use case was
to
build a larger storage base and compute
platforms right one of their major
applications was web so they used to
crawl web and capture all the page
information and build some sort of graph
to
further downstream applications so the
majority of the use case was you know
bring the data computed once a day or
twice a day so regardless they focus on
batch processing right so we all know
for the past few years uh
becomes more mainstream in the data
processing applications throughout the
enterprise a lot of customers started
using way more than what they're
designed for right and anytime you ask a
developer then you can only strengthen
them so far in the implementation then
you need a new accordion right so that
was the thought process behind hadoop or
the next generation of the new platform
so we see today lots of online
applications like streaming applications
as well as getting data cast or analyze
faster is more important for our
customers right and we all realize that
every customer we walk to they have
large amount of clusters where they want
to process the data faster right
if you want to do a fraud protection you
want to know right away rather than
waiting three five minutes when a
nigerian friend sent to me
i'm sure everybody got that email but
the idea is to process that fast enough
so when it started we know this is our
old map reduce well-known framework that
we all love and we all agree today uh
from a conceptual point of view they
only had a centralized job tracker which
used as a centralized scheduling
resource management engine as well as an
application engine
it does both application management and
resource management so you have a job
tracker where you submit a job and you
have tax tracker where they execute all
the jobs right very simple you have per
node agent or
displays what we call task tracker they
execute the test they record backing the
job tracker
off you have your uh
job clear
but
while it lasted great for us for the
past few years it had its own
limitations right and we saw that for
past few years
as a company we managed java's
infrastructure
too and we have seen the limitations
going on so one of the limitations we
saw is we cannot scale the clusters
beyond 4 000 now and not here
everybody has 4 000 nodes but there is a
scalability issue
the other issue we saw is as the
hardware keeps growing and growing you
can get all the uh all the analysis done
in less amount of hardware that you
already have right so whatever you have
done with 4000 node with the size of
hardware today you can create a
potential of 2000
because hardware is growing every year
potentially every six months
the other issue we saw was a concurrent
task so maximum concurrent task we were
able to run for 40 000 right in those
clusters and
it depends on everybody's application
but we saw we wanted to go beyond that
maximum to the currency status the
reason behind that is if you if you
think uh if you look at mapreduce
onenote the
the resources are basically split into
your map slots and reduce lots
and what we've seen is people wrote
application then they just use map slot
and they never use reduce logic right so
even though you haven't used lots
configured you're essentially wasting
memory and resources when you configure
that right it's in mapreduce10 it's
stealing memory from your resources so
the idea was to utilize the cluster
better with the same amount of resources
and we have some numbers uh for our
testing what we have done and i'll share
that with you in the next few slides
the other thing was the course
synchronization and job tracker because
job tracker does both resource
management as well as application
management
and over the period of time we realize
application management is hard right
basically from design perspective but
what job tracker has to do on its own
because it's tracking your job it's
looking at you know a lot of
counters it's looking at the tasks it's
doing preemption
all that's happening on a single dna so
we couldn't scale because if the job
tracker failed there's another issue and
if application has some issues you know
the job tracker signal demon needs to be
involved
availability right so failure to use
caused a lot of problems and not in a
smaller environment when you're talking
a 40 000 application going hard at this
cluster there are certain issues that
you know has a snowball effect right so
we wanted to make sure that an
application management and resource
management way is separate and we can
control that granularly right so that's
one of the design principle that they
they based upon
low use resource utilization we talked
about you know as macro-use deals more
resources because some of the unused
resources you cannot effectively utilize
so
how about taking a granular access to
every resource right we've seen certain
customers they have are running on
existing cluster and our guys just wrote
some scripts that obviously took all the
resources and you had no resource
running for an app to use a lot so the
idea is to control what you can give to
the application as well as have better
you know application management and
obviously lack of support right so we
wanted to have the more real-time
applications in uh hadoop and we are
seeing this
you know you have integrated sql coming
up with cloudera
ibm as well as barcelona stinger project
that's coming up fast and furious but
given the mapreduce paradigm we're still
stuck at same factories one until we go
to that next step as tez for example as
an application right so to enable those
applications in the next generation
framework and that's why we started our
the guys started working on uh yarn
about four years ago so they submitted
to uh uh around 2008 time frame and the
real work really done last couple of
years okay so
we all know this in hadoop 100 you have
single cluster resource management it's
highly coupled in
hdfs is a great
file system
which is
which can scale which is redundant and
can store your data very cheaply and
reliably
and we want to take that further having
this centralized data repository and
have all the applications access to that
data essentially using a singular
resource framework right and effectively
utilize more resources on that
so store data in one place with sdfs
access that data in the same place and
have all the application use
the resources available in this cluster
rather than having i have this
edge-based cluster i have a streaming
cluster i have this mapreduce cluster
and we want to combine those resources
together
so today we uh we started around two
months ago during college events we
started the yarn certification program
so we're working with a lot of companies
uh so that they can
work with us as well as by themselves
obviously uh to test and certify their
applications
right so we work with uh you know strong
guys drop guides as well as you know
open mdi guides right so open mpis
uh
can now
negatively run on yarn as well right so
npi is a message passive framework is
more
cpu intensive rather than disc offensive
but now we're able to run that in the
centers in the same cluster in the same
hadoop cluster specifically right
so
five key benefits if you don't remember
anything what i say today just take this
slide with you right one is scale we
want to scale beyond this limit of 4 000
nodes not necessarily 4 000 but
effectively utilize the cluster
resources because when the roads do form
out and over the period evolved their
idea was six processors or eight
processors in the machine 32 gig gram
and you know four terabyte disks were
great
now if you ask that that's one of your
desktops right a server is now running
24 cores 128 gigs of 2560 gram and
significant amount of storage space in a
singular two year clock right
and
we're not able to effectively take
advantage of that research so in order
to scale
not only beyond 4000 node but you don't
scale
vertically on that particular physical
hardware as well right
support new programming models and we'll
talk about that a little bit and andrew
will talk about that quality goes
through uh the application build
improve cluster utilization we talked
about this now once if you look at map
reviews now mapreduce becomes a user
land library in new york right so that
the other applications can generally
access and request resources
agility
is cheap
one of the things that we want to focus
on agility is because we all know if you
if you're going to go through this
motion of
upgrading hadoop one cluster to the
youtube cluster it's a little bit
challenging and we all agree to that
because a lot of things has changed
right you got to upgrade the cluster
take down time and you know there are no
severely rolling upgrades available
right so
going beyond hadoop2o when the new
upgrades come in the idea is to have all
your applications
run in the same framework without a
downtime right so the idea is to have
mapreduce one after these two as well as
all the posts run within the same
cluster while you're doing the upgrades
so making rolling upgrades
you know make agility better because you
don't have to take down time as well as
you don't have to go to your customer
and say hey we're upgrading this cluster
we're upgrading this you know resource
management now you need to update your
application so
when you update the system they can
eventually move to that particular new
code or
you know new system that they're using
98 of hadoop is all java right so we're
going to support other
other
applications where you use you can use
sequential python natively to do easily
right we still can do that today but
there's still
a difficult path of using that so going
beyond java was one of the critical
component of another skill so think
about these five aspects and they are
important when designing r right
um for
those who like history right so one of
the jira was created in 2008 it was
april 269 pretty specific
and uh led the pmc by earl morgan they
submitted it because yeah
originally had a significant issue of
utilization
um we've been working on yarn for past
three four years so now uh it has been
quite stable and we're running your arms
at the abdomen for
past six months or so so we started
deploying that in yahoo around january
time frame when we
had the opportunity to do so
there is no cluster today in yahoo runs
on mapreduce one everything runs on yarn
and hdfs2
so far we have deployed 35 000 nodes
in production there are significant
applications running in gapu and i have
some numbers in few slides that can that
can give you an idea
we're able to increase the utilization
so if you had an opportunity to listen
to the keynote that yahoo delivered at
hadoop summit
they went from 65 000
concurrent jobs to that cluster to 135
000 job on the same cluster on the same
hardware so they're utilizing more and
more by deploying this framework and it
has been running for past six months
with two releases of yards so it's been
quite stable and we're looking at as a
community we are looking at releasing
sga by september and timeframe so
september and you'll have hadoop to your
full ta on hdfs2 as well as yarn
uh questions when you talk about this
node
in production
for six months so all these previously
mapped
there are five clusters of roughly seven
thousand notes on enough of uh probably
running uh full long yarn hours
um
so
for for
from an er perspective they're using
data really so they all go ga so there's
some significant differences that
they'll go from theta to ga right so
there are some of the jiras that created
during that time frame that will get
incorporated so it's a six space testing
cycle so they go forward
and they are crazy
so
for them it's not necessarily today as
an enterprise because for them
so so far for from the testing using
close to ten thousand nodes um on
that's where the ceiling was the marker
we had in the history scale but uh we
haven't seen more than that yet the neon
will
i mean ten thousand dollars in a class
yes even that
all right so some of the basic concepts
already are there are two things that
you need to remember one is
application so application can be a job
submitted to yarn
so let's think of this return is a
resource scheduler on a distributed
computing environment right so you can
think of this way
it's like an application or os running
top of this
you know thousands of nodes and clusters
right and
it can give you ability to run resources
like cpu and memory and going forward
they'll keep adding disk resources uh
networks so you can control what it is
so as your application asking a linux
server give me you know two cpu two
vcpus and four gig memory for my
applications to run whereas yarn enables
you to do so on these hundreds of them
or even two of those what andrew is
going to show you today right
the second second example is a job you
can submit as a job which can run as a
service or under the job right so when
you submit a job like a mapreduce it
becomes a job for yarn also right but
when you look at yarn you can run
application as a persistent service
within yarn let's say you want to run
hbase on a hadoop tool that becomes an
application for yarn but it's a
persistent application right you start
the application it runs as long as you
want and for example massive use is a
job because when the job is run it
terminates after the job is done
the second concept is a container so
container is a basic resource or basic
unit of allocation so container
essentially is a resource allocation
given to you by resource manager right
and resource manager basically give you
a container today in yarn only for
memory and cpu right as the current
release goes uh in the future releases
by i think next year time frame will
have they'll keep adding to it they'll
have network resources you can consume
as well as disk io and you know storage
space
and possibly these are you know endless
so whatever you think of unix c group it
uses c groups underneath so if unit c
groups enables you to do that they'll be
basically exposed to beyond as well
i
job control and windows correct so not
only aren't support your linux but
we actually have yarn support and
windows as well so if you're owning
windows which how many of you do i don't
know but if you run new custom windows
instead of using c groups there's a job
control in
windows that can that give you the same
ability to control resources within
windows environment thank you
how many people have
you know in your experience at orton
have you seen many people running with
your window
there
we have so far three or four customers
all right so that's a good point right
so microsoft originally
from a shipping mechanism perspective
this it will deliver to the inside but
then it was kind of restricted so what
we did is we compiled for
a separate download for hadoop on
windows so certain customers they have
just the windows environment you don't
want to go
get linux or any type of building so we
have seen very small customers using
that
when ga are on main time frame so we
haven't seen you know significant
adoption as well
so the question was any performance
difference on hadoop on windows
right so
given the testing and the scale we have
done the answers no because they totally
offer a windows 2012 right so 2012 comes
with a file system which is the next
generation file system that i think
those offer right so that's basically a
significant performance improvement
so called rfs reliable file systems
that's one of the things that they
worked on with veritas
shipping now within those 2011.
so your answer is
now feature comparison-wise between unix
and windows i think that you have to do
that but performance-wise on hdfs purely
yes
and there are certain guidelines that
you need to follow to get that
performance that obviously you can't get
all right so from architectural
perspectives right as you
know or all love the mapreduce one it's
kind of the same but it's just great so
what's the similarity the similarity is
there's a centralized resource manager
which controls the resources within the
customer right which all fits the
resources and you know keep track of
resources within the cluster it's like a
job tracker
every other node right within the
cluster around something called as node
manager like previously you had a fast
track the node manager
is the one who has responsibility to out
in the control to use those containers
allocated to that node management right
so we saw container is the basic unit of
allocation which is cpu and memory given
to you by resource the resource manager
the third thing is the application
manager so now in this case application
manager is where your application runs
it is nothing different or magical about
it it's just a container where you
deploy your application right
and it's a little bit hierarchical right
so when you
and andrew will go to the code but when
a client requests an application to be
deployed it essentially submits a
request to resource manager resource
managers come back and say okay you want
uh you know six gigabyte of memory two
virtual cpus great i will give you a
container on
node number a right that's your
application manager when the application
starts it has responsibility to get
containers
for whatever it's needs right so you'll
go back to resource manager and say okay
i need two containers on this particular
host or you know give me where you can
find the resources right so all the
containers will be the children of the
application manager and the application
managers will be the children of the
resource manager so so on investor how
many instances of
resource manager
and the application manager are
recommended
so on a cluster there'll be only one
resource manager okay right and at the
moment there's a tierra
in progress where they will make
resource manager highly available
they'll come in 2-1 if i'm right or
whatever time frame but the resource
manager definitely is coming so that
it's like a job tracker here on the
screen right okay but the beauty is your
resource manager is not
in path like the job tracker it's not
doing application management so the
resource manager goes down you restart
the resource manager on another node or
same or whenever you fix it you can
still
have your application keeps running
right the bottom line is when the
resource manager goes down you're not
going to get any new resources right
whereas in job tracker job drivers wrote
down your jobs are not in progress
we'll get
you sent me 10 000 jobs
right
so from a resource manager perspective
right you think of it as a job tracker
it has a responsibility of global
resource schedules right it knows how
many resources are available within the
structure it keeps track of you know
just know it has you know xmr resources
is allocated i if the application is
managing an application measure
requesting more resources we can
allocate to that
it is it basically supports hierarchical
cues so we still have the uh scheduling
cues or capacity schedule allocated with
yarn so you can say you know group a
within my company gets forty percent of
the resources will be as you know
whatever thirty percent of the resources
it is still centrally managed from the
capacity perspective but the resource
manager is the one who is controlling
those resources
nerd manager as we saw it's a pro
machine agent right it basically uh
manages the life cycle of that container
right it hosts the container
within the container your code runs and
it's basically running on that
particular node right so that's your
slave
for for a particular uh for your
particular cluster
node mapping is also responsible for
container resource monitoring right
previously job tracker was tracking all
these in the resource monitoring or
entire cluster whereas we have separated
that for individual resources that's
done by node manager where the container
resides okay
application manager right so it's per
application
so you can spawn
as many application masters you want
right so if you submit a map reviews job
because now your mapreduce job becomes a
user library if they it'll spawn a
application master it'll ask for the
resources or containers from a resource
manager and execute what it feeds to
execute and then basically give the
containers away right
edge space for example hbase on yarn
your hbase faster server will be your
application master you'll be persistent
as long as you basically give the
resources away right so that's basically
the application master
it manages the tasks you know it manages
the application scheduling and tasks
whereas it is responsible for
requesting resources what it needs so
there's no longer a concept of job
tracker doing all this resource
management for you if you need resources
go ask resource manager when you're done
with resources free of those resources
and resource manager will track all
those responses
you also manage and monitor your own
you know children or containers there's
no responsibility of the
resource management so if one of the
node where it's running the containers
dies it's the application manager's
responsibility to go to the resource
manager and say hey i need four more
containers for my job to run
whereas if your application master dies
it's his parents responsibility an
application is manager product parent is
basically a resource manager
so
application manager is dead for example
node dies the resource manager will
restart that application manager on some
other node where you have the space or
resources available right so it's always
hierarchical so the children to the
parents of the parents
the most professional applications
so
if
right so there's a capacity scheduler
right so depending on how much capacity
is allocated to you right you will get
that capacity so let's say you're group
a and you only have 20 of the cluster
resources you cannot ask more than 25
resources if you have a hard quota but
if you have no quota you can
ask for as much as resources you want
only
yeah only it's available to give it back
to you right there's a there's a concept
of soft coda as well so if you have 20
of the cluster resource we have soft
quota and the resources are available
you can you know go back and get that
resources all right
so so if an application
master died
would like wouldn't we it's not uh
like the road manager experience like in
a hierarchical order like resource
manager and the node manager and then
the application master now so if the
application master dies there's an
application context and then you cover
that in a in your in in the in the code
review right so the application context
basically makes uh the identity of the
application manager uh available to the
resource manager so it is aware that
this is your application manager because
this is the first container that was
asked by the user code okay and if it
basically identifies that is an
application master and it is responsible
for restarting that
and no dying is basically again if the
node is
let's say the node has application
masters and other containers on that
node so it's good here so let's say i
have containers here right this compares
this one this em2 containers are on this
guy too
and if this application master dies and
this container also dies this am2 will
request the resource manager that i need
another container because that container
guide is dead but resource manager will
basically see that this application
master is dead you'll spawn that
application master as container zero on
some other node whereas it's his
responsibility to get this container 1.2
so the reason that
the
application manager is not the child of
the node managers because you need to
request
resources resources across the cluster
if you only could
ask these losses within the same node
then
that makes sense right well so if load
manager cannot give you any resources
for application and they're asking
anything a node manager doesn't make
sense right you only can go to the
resource manager who has a central
repository of resources and say give me
the resources you can ask that i want a
resources on this particular node right
and the resources are available you'll
get it you can also say
uh you know give me resources on in this
rack anywhere they'll give you the
resources it is essentially locality
aware right because if you say i want i
want resources on node whatever this
node is direct manager number two and if
the neural niner two is you know for
whatever reason it's not available a in
exhausted resources b is down
your yard will essentially try to
allocate resources first on that
particular rack because of the locality
of the data because you think that for
your application it's important you'll
be hosted on that node and yarn thinks
next in the algorithm that next to this
node in the same rack is more important
rather than giving you on this
particular raptor if nothing is
available on that rack then you know
sorry let's go find it
let's say you have hype and the
so how would the clients know that af2
is where i should come in
so that's a good question right so i
think
when you say you connect to five
different data
you will basically start to save with
command line
and you submitted
uh and query and guess converted into a
job
so you just have to talk to your source
manager and it figures out where to send
it
not call it hype let's say it's an
application you run application master
and
it goes down your clients have to go
elsewhere right so this classic failover
scenario and think about just regular
education here
there's no automatic way to do it but if
you let's say deploy one of these as
fast as a load balance uh and have your
settings
for example
uh
we won't go into details today but you
can look
at page based on your blog post on our
site
and they go to the actual workflow what
happens
why
it's very interesting to follow and
gives you discovery to the reliable
applications so they basically put all
the balance
the other thing you can do is something
called blacklist or whitelist right so
let's say you have this hype server
running on node a the only thing for
that application manager whitelist
available
i don't know it's the other way i always
get confused right here blacklist right
so let's assume that this application
manager can only run these two nodes so
basically you'll find responsibility to
check on one of these so you can do that
in simple dns handling or cname or
whatever you have in your environment so
in a in a white list scenario again
check whiteboards or blackboard you can
control where those application manager
agents are right
okay so we've already covered that okay
so
the design
one of the design you know question was
for their design decision was
basically split these resources we said
the application management is hard
because
the job tracker is doing not only
cluster resource management but the
application management as well right so
it's doing speculative execution it's
collecting
it collecting the information on every
task what's the what's the progress on
the task is right if the task dies it's
basically handling the
redundancy on the task the task is dead
notice that it goes fondly tasked on the
other node so it's running on the same
daemon so if you're running on you know
basically we separate those rules now
you have this hundreds of application
master they're doing their own resource
for application management not their
resource management they're doing their
communication with their containers
they're managing their task progress
resource manager is only responsible for
you know you ask for resources here you
go so they wanted to basically separate
the resource manager and make it
completely agnostic of application
management that's what yarn is all about
is the resource manager for the entire
cluster right
and we talked about this mapreduce
becomes a
user library so let's see what happens
right so in a typical
yarn application or yara architecture
your client comes in it asks for
resources to learn management it's the
same way you went to dog tracker you
submit a job in this case you basically
go to resource manager and ask for
research and you'll see when you undergo
there's a specific api call
for doing that right
what
resource manager says okay i have
this node where you ask for six
gigabytes and you know four vcpus i'll
give you a container that's your initial
container called compare zero and you'll
start that job on that particular uh
start application manager on that node
now once the application manager started
and you'll see the application context
and what what kind of application you
want to run and it's fairly flexible
once that application line responds it's
his responsibility to say okay i would
like to run this code on
10 things for 10 notes so application
manager will go back to the
application manager resource manager
client and say okay give me four
containers or buy containers in this
case i got container number 2.1
and then we'll talk over a different
api called
application manager to node manager and
say go mr node start this container for
me and this container has you know
this resources as well as you know i
would like to start with you and you and
you
so if
the
idea is not to hard code it so if your
application needs a resources to
dynamically grow or reduce
you can
demand those resources as your demand
grows or as your demand shrinks you can
release those resources so there's no
hard coding like map reviews that i need
100 containers to begin with so if you
ask 100 containers depending on
your capacity you will get it but then
essentially that's your hard limit as
you said right what's my limit so once
you schedule what that quota is for the
particular user approved you're going to
get that many resources but the idea is
not to there's not necessarily need to
have those resources to begin with
same thing right so
you got the containers
now if i need additional resources i'm
going to go back to resource manager and
say i need resource on this to know
right and it will spawn that article
right
i'm going to go back to the same slide
so important things of the concept right
to go going through the building the
applications right so two things you
need to understand one is an application
so application
for yarn is essentially a
service or an application can be a
mapreduce library
battery use job within the yarn second
thing is the container container is
essentially a
smallest unit or a basic unit allocation
so you have memory and cpu today and
eventually you have disk and network
resources
two things you have
as architecture-wise you have resource
manager who is there who is responsible
for resources throughout the cluster and
manages it
the second thing you have is essentially
load manager so the node manager is the
demon running on all the nodes who hosts
all the container
the third
important point is application manager
which basically runs in your default
container zero
and it spawns the resources it's always
child parent relationships it's a
resource you request from your client
that i need resources response
application manager application manager
request the resource manager to get
resources it does what it needs to do
and release the resources as you know
after after the application is done
in other words
you know like the old way you can have
job crackers on uh
depending on the larger cluster it's it
typically becomes celsius
just hold on to that thought two slides
down you have you know ice
uh
so
today
this is the last time i'll run through
and then i'll hand it over for running
through how to build an application
right so well what we have so far is
so far we have
oh yeah right this is what happens when
you have engineers to name the product
but it's nothing but beautiful europe
and we are going to we can't name goethe
we can already have the computer-wise
that's giraffe from iran but that's you
know the different story right so we the
code is not modified at all from a space
perspective it's just that deployment is
different on
as well as we have storm and s4 already
certified on earth so you can deploy the
code today
um
test the generic framework for a running
complex dag which eventually will become
the processing engine under high will be
released as beta
september time frame and full ga
in january so it also runs on earth it
is designed from ground up that's a part
of stinger pro stinger initiative for
right making high faster
mpi we talked about uh we had spark and
drop and master worker we already have
them certified and you can you know
download the code from them as well as
from
you know if you have existing code you
can run on the r directly
that's the bottom line right run
everything on the same cluster utilize
the resources scale agility right and
having
cluster which can take advantage of all
the resources so that's basically what
uran is it's it's a resource scheduler
for next generation of the field so it's
not from hadoop one or hadoop two it's
not just a code rep it's really the next
generation of resource scheduling so it
really fits fast
question about the activities on beyond
we can take any or i can take any
actually it's released from apache and
install only on yes okay four edge-based
releases for that matter because there's
no restrictiveness right okay because
all yarn does it gives you resources
yarn doesn't care what you're on it is
completely exhausted the iron doesn't
necessarily need hdf that's also it's
just the resource scheduler so you first
say and that's the beauty that's that's
adds to agility right so today you have
hbase 0.92 running and you have some
hardcore things you did in your
application that needs that specific
thing you can run
that as an application master and you
can run at 0.94 with whiteness enabled
side by side and control the resources
it does not create a more layer between
the actuators and sdf we already have
like people there no but
there's not right so it it doesn't make
any difference because htf edge based
responsibility doctor hdfs it's not
yours responsibility yarn is all saying
you need resources i'll give it to you
it's in your code how you get the data
from hdfs you want to get the data from
nfs here go go do it in your code you
write a perl script and run postscript
across all the nodes you can do it the
code is going to run is simply a shell
script and it's going to go run date
across all the nodes there's nothing in
htfs for that matter you can run
anything you want and that's basically
the next thing is you don't want to run
a specific javascript you can just run
the shell script yeah the separate
question
on the monitoring side so how do we
pinpoint about how
but if you start running a yarn cluster
you will always see what's going on
there
so the question is how do you how do you
monitor it right yeah
so the ganglia extensions will be
available for yarn also right so they
manage to
essentially report on node manager and
resource management
you already have ganglion instances or
ganglia extensions for edge base
hdfs high and what have you right so
those will stay the same where they get
deployed you can deploy a bank extension
all those when you start gambling you're
basically looking for
a high demon running on that particular
node right or a specific node so that
doesn't change the only thing is a
vision to it is basically the extension
performing our resource manager and node
manager there's no fast track or
anything right so those are those that i
want to change
how does it process the state
who does process so how does
master or resource community this is the
stream so
so your resource writer is not aware of
any jobs in flight or in progress the
research manager says you're the
application manager you're running a
application which needs 10 000
containers right okay
do you have
um you know do you well from from a
capacity perspective do you are you the
user we can give you that capacity if
the answer is yes you're going to get
that resources if you don't
i'll say capacity schedule say oh you
can only get 20 of the cluster and you
have your 100 resources you're not going
to get 10 000 units you're going to get
10 at a time but once you've got those
units you're running something there so
who's tracking that so that's your
problem with application plan so you're
on a job your application manager is
sponsored for tracking that progress of
the application
it can be a mapreduce job you submit it
to your it
so if you keep the application last
regional services
you can still
create hbase and just use the
configuration location because space
configuration of the cluster and every
time you resize the plastic program you
just
so understand you are no longer
restricted to running as much use and
you are no longer restricted to talking
to each other
djfs
don't get neuron is a great means to
distribute the behavior and deploy the
without the pedal
and create some requests sometimes we
just want to talk to this or you want to
talk to
some network to do it
if you're running an arc or you just
want to drop your local disk you can do
that
technically no but it's it's basically
coupled together as a powerful relief so
it's always being doubled as it is you
want to build your arm by separating yes
the other thing is for a mattress you
can another point right so the mapreduce
is a little bit modified so now when you
run a mapreduce as a user library
what happens is anything is going on as
a state of mapreduce job it writes as a
transaction log into hdfs so if your map
reduced job is progressing we're writing
that
status of the mapreduce in hdfs so when
your application manager fails where
you're running the code what's going to
happen is when we restart the
application manager we're going to look
for that uri and he's going to point it
to you that application context where
the uri could be important and that
we're going to read that uri and say
okay this is where the task was and i'm
going to restart application manager to
continue from that point on right
typically today job tracker fails you
resume everything right and that will go
away because that's one of the things
that built into it a couple of things
that got into uh
into that code is the clients now can
wait so the client if you're using an
hdfs client high client or any other
client they have pause and retry
mechanism so the master service in this
case the application master fails while
it's getting restarted the client will
pause and it'll keep retrying until the
service comes back online so the pause
and return mechanism is already in the
deployment the map reduce two
transaction logs according to htfs and
let resource manager start in uh it's
part of the army
so so if i understand it correctly when
when hbase is running online
the h master is this an instance of uh
application management correct in space
that's not the argument at all it's just
launched by your infrastructure okay
so
but essentially h mastery will run
inside an application management data
um
and so so for mapreduce what is the
equivalent i mean uh
like the edgemaster is still there right
it is running either in a container or
in the application manager
for mapreduce
what we used to call job driver what is
that now that runs in ourselves think
about node managers they actually run
broadcast
it's not exactly not the threaded plus
say
multiple parallel processes will run on
different knowledge
the big difference now is if you have
these ones you have to split your
cluster and say i have 10
uh metaphors and fiber gifts
and if even if you are not doing any use
operations you are wasting customers
so does it consider data localization
also
it's uh it's a cool level it tries to
execute the task as close to it as
possible
but that's in mapreduce there's nothing
to do with yarn yarn has uh i mean in a
nutshell the artist is data local aware
right so when you start a macro use job
you're going to still ask me name node
that's where all in hdfs20 it's in your
namespace so you're going to go to one
of your names and say where are my
blocks for these files and it's going to
say okay here are these blocks the
application manager is going to be
responsible to start the task on groups
so it's going to go to the resource
guide and say give me containers on here
here and here this host this host and
discos that's what you request right and
now if that's not available we're going
to start on the same rack because we
assume that you know the data locality
of the hdfs works is first copy and one
node second copy on the same rack third
copies elsewhere so that's in the map
application yarn is basically waiting
okay where do you need resources you
will figure out what your data locality
is
does that make sense
so application manager will be aware
application manager is basically a
container it's not it's a computer
so the application running within the
application manager shouldn't be a rare
data location
just understand the way you can choose
so you're saying now name north so you
start your application manager okay so
where it is
so let's go here you started your
mapreduce code your application start
says okay i need to process
you know web blog one okay so it's going
to go ask within the application name
node says where is web block one lost
it's going to tell you it's here here
and here
what's the next step is going to happen
it's going to say okay i need containers
here and here and here to process these
blocks so it's going to go to the
resource menu and say give me container
here here and here
and then your code is going to execute
resource manager is not aware of
what exactly blocks you're looking at
it's your application
right the application manager basically
responsible for managing freezing
service the region a failover
responsibility of application maps
okay so if none of the need know which
way
there are possibility that there are two
region servers
yeah
there can be more
manager if the resources are available
yeah okay
you cannot have that too you cannot get
there because because your team will run
okay so two region servers are two
containers or two applications
you
what else you get from the artists not
just those systems
so when when you get a container you get
something called a container id and a
token id okay from a resource manager
token id is essentially a
handshake
between the research manager and the
node director
or the particular container so they only
responsible that this context is only
available for this application manager
you and within that content you have
these many resources so you have two
cpus and whatever for gigabyte memory so
you cannot override that container by
expanding the resources or basically
tagging one of any other containers
because you're you only have that
particular id so it's basically token
based from from a communication
again it's security too
you can't really go across the past
yes i have one question i think this
will be pretty quick
um so right now it's just uh
resources resource allocation so if i
have hbase and
giraffe or spark on the same yard
cluster there's no currently no real
cross application compatibility yet it's
just if i wanted to run
spark machine learning on top of my
hbase data spark will still need to go
through the
region servers to pull it out the term
spark you need full hpc api calculator
okay then basically your response back
right now if they're running on the same
server
this guy runs 20 percent here
they're all running on the same hdfs
uh if there's some kind of cross
compatibility like oh i can just talk to
the hbase
files themselves but not yet well i mean
from uh from after use perspective yeah
there is a direct access to files
uh it's an hdfs api right there is no
direct access or deals that give me this
all the communication happens exactly
the same you go to the internet ask for
the resources to get it in college based
api you go get it right if it's a storm
you created a bolt to inject the data
onto hdfs it's still going to talk to me
in order to tell me where you can
gesture data if you're strong
fair enough thanks thanks